[Music]
vertex ai
is an end-to-end platform for machine
learning development and deployment
it includes a suite of new products and
services to support mlaps
i'll introduce some of the key pieces
vertex pipelines feature store and model
monitoring
the backbone of the vertex mlaps story
is vertex pipelines
which lets you automate and orchestrate
your machine learning workflows
vertex pipelines is scalable serverless
and cost effective
and supports gcp standard enterprise
security controls
you can focus on specifying your
pipelines without worrying about
infrastructure
and you pay only for the resources that
you use
when pipelines execute run metadata is
automatically logged
this allows lineage tracking
reproducibility comparisons across
runs metrics visualization and more
let's take a quick look at how these
pipelines are defined
vertex pipelines supports two
easy-to-use python sdks
kfp and tfx pipelines are built using
reusable components
and many pre-built components exist
including those for
vertex ai services here we're building
an automl
image classification workflow we'll just
compile this pipeline
and run it right from the notebook like
this
then we can view the running pipeline in
the console ui
while the pipeline is running or after
it is finished you can view the pipeline
step logs and generated artifacts and
metadata
and if you want to build your own
components this is easy to do as well
automating orchestration is not the
complete picture though
one common set of pain points revolves
around feature engineering
feature reuse and sharing serving
features at scale and with low latency
and avoiding training serving skew the
vertex feature store helps solve these
problems
it reduces the cycle time of ml
deployments by making it easy to share
discover and serve features at scale
after you've trained
evaluated and deployed your model you're
not done you still need to pay attention
to the performance of your model over
time
if model drift occurs it may be
necessary to retrain or tune the model
vertex model monitoring helps with both
alerting and diagnosis
you can set up a monitoring job for a
deployed model and get alerts when there
are anomalies
you can configure monitoring objectives
for model features and get distribution
[Music]
stats
you